the
new york city police commissioner
just spoke over the past few days
over a terrible attack on police
officers in harlem
two officers were shot one of them was
killed while responding to a domestic
call up in harlem which used to be a
terrible neighborhood
then it got much much better much much
safer and now it's getting terrible
again here's the police commissioner
tonight
a 22 year old
son
husband
officer
and friend
was killed
because he did what we asked him to do
countless officers lined the halls of
this hallway after carrying him in and
grieve for their brother
while praying with everything they have
for the other
i am struggling to find the words to
express the tragedy we are enduring
we're mourning
and we're angry we have four times this
month rushed to the scene of nypd
officers shot by violent criminals in
possession of deadly illegal guns i'll
ask mayor adams if he wants to say a few
words
the police commissioner has a lot of
passion in her voice
obviously this is a tragic event
but she doesn't have a lot of substance
in her speech you notice that
she says she's struggling to find the
words
i've got the words here are very simple
words
mayor adams
fire your weak prosecutors who are
refusing to prosecute criminals
and put those criminals in jail
those are pretty simple words
but she can't find them
i don't know why look maybe it's because
she's serving the mayor of new york the
weak mayor of new york
who refuses to deal with the crime issue
and so maybe she doesn't feel that she
has the political capital to talk about
this but if she's simply struggling to
find the words let me give you the words
mayor adams fire your derelict
prosecutors
who refuse to do their jobs and put
criminals in jail very very simple words
right now inflation is at 40-year highs
and it's here to stay because the
government's dirty little secret is
they want it
they do they want the inflation right
now inflation rates are higher than the
interest on treasury bonds so what does
that mean that means every day that
passes the government owes less on its
mountain of debt
imagine if you had a mortgage that had a
negative interest rate would you be in a
hurry to pay it off i don't think so so
your pain is their gain
protect your savings right now hedge
against inflation with gold from birch
gold
because the government is sabotaging the
value of the us dollar birch gold will
help you convert an eligible ira or 401k
into an ira backed by real gold
that is peace of mind that is why i love
birch gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a-plus rating from the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
to
989898 to get a free info kit on holding
gold in a tax sheltered account then
call birch and protect your hard earned
savings text knowles k wles to
989898 to get your free info kit now
most defensive about this speech
did you hear that little bit she gets in
there she says this this
happened
she insinuated quite strongly this
happened
because of illegal guns
that's what's changed in new york is
that there are guns around
there
there have been guns around new york for
a very long time illegal guns too for a
very long time clearly the gun laws
aren't working that well
what has changed in the past few years
is not
that
there are new gun sales in new york
legal or illegal what has changed is not
that there's there are new guns being
manufactured that that are
dramatically different from the old guns
that were being manufactured
what has changed in new york is that
prosecutors won't do their job
because there is a new
leftist idea that the police are bad and
criminals are put upon and we need to be
tougher on the cops and weaker on the
criminals and we when when criminals
riot and loot and burn down buildings
during blm especially in new york we're
just going to let them off the hook
we're going to give them much lower
charges when we charge them at all and
for the majority of them the vast
majority of them we're just going to let
them off completely
and then you're surprised when crime
goes up
when the administration in new york
says the de blasio administration in
particular the one right before this new
mayor says
certain crimes are no longer going to be
considered crimes and then when the
prosecutors come in and say even when
you do commit the crimes we're not going
to charge you for them and then you're
shocked when crime goes up
so fine i'm not
i'm not saying that this woman has it
entirely in her power
she's the police commissioner
but
spare me the sanctimony spare me the
emotion if you're not going to put any
substance behind it you're right there
the mayor's right there in the room use
there are the words feel free to borrow
them from me i won't won't be offended
at all i'm so glad you like that clip
that makes me feel great that you liked
it you watched it now i hope you click
the like button i hope you i hope you
like maybe left me a comment but what i
really hope is
you ring the bell
that way you'll get the notifications we
can be together again and even if we
don't get the notifications for whatever
reason
youtube
uh you can head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
subscribe
leave a five star review
the michael knowles show we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]